carcinoma of the lung is a serious
disease and we're all very much
concerned about it
not only because it is the most frequent
of all cancers
but also because the prognosis is so bad
the reason the prognosis is bad is that
carcinoma of the lung is early and
geoinvasive
we've found that of all the patients
going through our pulmonary function
laboratory
in whom we find a cancer of the lung
that 40 percent of them have tumor cells
in their peripheral arterial blood
in those in which the lesion is in the
in the periphery it's 70 percent whereas
those in which the lesion is in the
higher portion of the lung it's 30
percent
the other tragic thing about cancer the
lung is that it is largely preventable
with the exception of adenocarcinoma
which is a rare disease and is
proportionally becoming rare all the
time and which has no relationship to
mediologic factor i'm going to discuss
in a moment
all other cancers of the lung are caused
by cigarette smoking so this is a
disease which has become the most
frequent of all cancers which is
preventable and which is one of our
great
public health hazards today as i
mentioned previously the results from
the treatment accounts of the lung are
not good as shown in this graph of all
the patients that we've seen now
representing over 3 500
only 50 percent are operable in other
words 50 percent of them the lesion is
already extended beyond the lung at the
time we see them only thirty percent of
the entire group are respectable and
only six percent of the entire group are
alive and apparently free from disease
at the end of five years
this is a man 52 years of age who began
with some mild discomfort in his left
chest an x-ray was taken it showed a
shadow in his lung this increased rather
rapidly within a very short period of
time as one can see here in the left uh
chest is a shadow apparently attached to
the chest wall from this we can't tell
whether it's in the lung or whether it
originated from the priorities
in the lateral wind and gram or the
black rather one can see that this is in
the parenchyma this man was a very heavy
smoker and because of his heavy smoking
we feel that quite definitely this is a
bronchogenic carcinoma we feel that
but the history of smoking is the most
positive method of making a diagnosis of
cancer the lung
cytology here showed tumor cells in the
sputum
the incision is made over the left fifth
rib
it begins anteriorly curves around the
angle of the scapula and then extends up
superiorly the patient is in the right
lateral decubitus so that the left chest
is up
one can either do the operation through
an intercostal incision
or one can resect the rib now i'm going
to recep the rib in this case because of
the lateral area the position of it now
i'm counting the ribs
because before the incision it's
impossible to tell just which is the
fifth rib but beginning above i'm
counting them and now here's the fifth
rib and i'm going to resect this
because of the lateral position of the
tumor i think that it is probably
adhered to the priorities i think
there's less danger of my
getting into tumor if i resect the rib
than if i make an intercostal incision
also i think they'll have less pain if
their rib is resected rather than an
intercostal incision
periosteum is peeled away from the rib
the resection is dubbed subperiosteally
and this helps to stabilize the chest
later
beginning posteriorly on the upper side
and anteriorly on the
lower side
we separate the periosteum the
periosteum is further separated from the
rib
with this instrument we call a joker
and then using the doion periosteal
elevator the periosteum is separated
from the rib
is used to divide the rib both
anteriorly and posteriorly
i'm incising through the
the bed of the rib
and
as i feared the lung is adhered in this
area i'm going to try and get an area
where it is free because i want to be
able to tell more about just what this
attachment is due to
now i'm in the free plural cavity
posteriorly
and as i feared the lung is adhered to
the
to the priorities and because this
adherence may be neoplastic
i'm going to do an extra plural
dissection
of the lung
now using this periosteal elevator i'm
separating the pleura from the
uh chest wall
and in this way if
the pleura is involved with neoplastic
lesion
there is not much likelihood of uh
implantation of tumor
now i've separated it one can see how
the
the parietal pleura is adhered to the
lung
now dividing the pleura
away from the chest wall above
now we're dividing it inferiorly
this is the part that we separated away
from the varieties
one can see the tumor
this is the attachment of the pleura to
the
lung and tumor
of course now we can't tell whether it's
neoplastic or not i'm trying to believe
that it's only inflammatory
the ribs are separated by means of the
fina queto
uh retractor
one can see this is a mediastinum
there's a phrenic nerve uh lying about
the mid portion of the of the frame
we're now freeing the mediastinum partly
by blunt dissection partly by sharp
dissection
we will get up and isolate the
pulmonary artery
there are a number of small branches
here
the pulmonary plexus
which are nerve fibers but there are
small vessels
along with them
and we are now getting a sem ligature
carrier around the pulmonary artery this
is the main branch of the pulmonary
artery the reason we do this is because
although we don't know yet whether we're
going to do a
pneumonectomy or lobectomy is that by
isolating the pulmonary artery and
getting a ligature on it we can control
any bleeding if it might occur in
separating the branches of the pulmonary
artery
this is another small branch a
vessel in the mediastinum which we're
ligating to prevent troublesome bleeding
this is another branch of the pulmonary
plexus that i've caught dividing
this will be ligated also
reading the mediastinum so far i haven't
encountered any
large nodes which appear to be involved
the uh the node under the the nodes
under the uh arch of the aorta
apparently are uninvolved
this is a pulmonary artery again which
i've
putting the ligature around
this is simply a precautionary measure
because as i said i don't know whether
we're going to do a lobectomy or a
pneumonectomy
i'm now
separating the individual branches of
the pulmonary artery
because
i i'm going to do a lobectomy if it
seems feasible and i can remove it the
reason for this is as i mentioned
earlier
uh the curability incidence in
carcinoma of the lung is low and we've
learned uh by sad experience that the
best way to
the best way to treat cancer along is to
do as little a
resection as one can and remove the
tumor grossly
dividing the
the superior branch of the pulmonary
artery
uh it has been ligated i'll transfix
this
because it's it's important to transfix
these vegetables since they are large
vessels in diameter as a matter of fact
their diameter is actually larger than
their
than their length and it's almost like
uh
ligating a funnel so that unless one
transfixes it one will
uh like there's likely breeding now i'm
getting some bleeding from the inferior
branch of the pulmonary artery at this
stage i didn't know what was causing
this
but we subsequently found out that this
was due to involvement of the artery by
the tumor
because of this we decided to do a
pneumonectomy because we felt that we
would not cure this man if we didn't do
a pneumonectomy
so now the pulmonary artery which i had
previously around which i previously put
a
a ligature is now being ligated
we put one on medially and distally and
then we put two transfection sutures
medially
these are placed in such a way that four
quadrants of the vessel are caught
one goes superiorly inferiorly
and the other goes anteriorly
posteriorly so that we have four
quadrants of the vessel caught as i've
previously mentioned this is necessary
because of the large diameter of the
vessel
and if one doesn't catch the four
quadrants there is likelihood of
slippage of the vessel
the diameter of the vessel being
actually larger than the length of the
vessel
using this technique however there is
little or no danger of hemorrhage
and this i found through the years to be
a very valuable method of handling the
uh pulmonary vessels
both the artery and the two pulmonary
veins
the first one first transfection
ligature
went
superiorly and inferiorly and this one
the second one goes anteriorly
posteriorly
so that the four quadrants are caught
after tying it anteriorly
the
suture is pulled around and tied
posteriorly so as to get the entire
segment
we now divide the
vessel leaving a relatively long segment
now we're
going to free the inferior pulmonary
ligament from the mediastinum
this is done uh by sharp dissection
there's some bleeding we catch the
the small vessels as we encounter them
we free this up to the to the inferior
pulmonary vein which is the most
inferior and posterior of the structures
now we're coming up to the
inferior pulmonary vein you can see it
here exposed
there's a node distally
which seems soft and i don't believe is
involved
a ligature is placed around the inferior
pulmonary vein
it is
held laterally
another one is placed medially
both these are tied one laterally and
one medially
and then as in the pulmonary artery
we will
put two transfixion sutures medially on
the cardiac side
this one goes
superiorly inferiorly
it's tied anteriorly and then will be
pulled around
and tied posteriorly
this is pulling the suture around and
tying it posteriorly
one should give sufficient time the
ligature to seat
because this is a big vessel
and it must be to pull down totally
now this is another suture this one goes
posteriorly anteriorly so that the four
quadrants of the vessel are caught
a
clamp has been applied to the vessel
distally
the ligatures are divided
and then the inferior pulmonary vein is
divided immediately adjacent to the
monument clamp leaving a relatively long
segment
on the cardiac side
now it's divided and one can see the the
sutured end of the inferior pulmonary
vein we next go up and isolate the
superior pulmonary vein
and do the same uh thing we put two
ligatures on one immediately one
distally two transfixion sutures
medially
a monument clamp distillate and then
division of the supreme performance vein
same technique is used for all three
vessels
now the spare pulmonary vein has been
divided
the vascular structures are now
separated from the lung
with the exception of the
bronchial arteries we now go back and
isolate and free the bronchus
the left main strand bronchus up to
the region of the bifurcation because we
don't want to lead a long
a stump
we're now freeing the bronchus from a
real tissue and any nodes that might be
in the hyler area
apparently there are none a bronchial
clamp is placed across the bronchus
relatively high just beyond the corina a
second one is placed distal to it
because we don't want any spillage from
the lung
and then
the bronchus is divided by means of this
right angled knife
now we have to
close the bronchus
whereas previously we used
mattress sutures now we use plastic
sutures
and this is a these are multiple sutures
the first one is placed at one end of
the clamp and tied
now because this is plastic one must use
many throws it's one of the disadvantage
of the plastic suture but the main
advantage is that is well tolerated and
since we've been using this technique
we've had no
trouble with uh bronchial stumps
it is important that these sutures be
brought up totally enough just to
approximate the
the edges of the bronchus but not too
tightly to cut through
one can cut through the bronchus
if one pulls too tightly
now a suture is placed at the other end
of the bronchus which is tied
around the end of the bronchus
in the same way the first suture was
tied
then we put in a row of sutures proximal
to the clamp but these are not tied
until after the clamp is removed
they are tagged by means of small
hemostats so that we won't get them
mixed up
as i said previously at one time we used
mattress sutures but we don't anymore
because we feel that interfered with the
blood supply now the clamp is removed
and the sutures which have been placed
are hell taught and in this way there is
little danger of leakage from the
bronchus while we ligate these sutures
again i want to emphasize that these are
tied only tight enough to approximate
the walls of the bronchus without
cutting through them
they're all tied individually
the fact that they've been tagged with
hemostats before makes it easy for us to
identify them and not get them mixed up
with one another
this is of importance i think
now the they've all been tied and one
can see that the closure is very good
now we're putting in saline because we
want to be sure that this is water tight
the anesthetist is now asked to
increase the intra bunkie pressure
by increasing the pressure on the bag
and you can see there's no leak this is
absolutely necessary because if there is
any leak we must put additional sutures
in to close it
since there is no leak we can now
remove the sutures
leaving them relatively long since they
are plastic
and now
we close over the bronchial stump
by suturing the flaps of pleura both
anteriorly and posteriorly over it this
i think is extremely important because
it tends to protect the bronchial stump
and prevent a blow out
i think as a result of this
uh
serous fluid is kept trapped in this
area which becomes
deposited as fibrin and then ultimately
organized so that it's actually like a
cap over the bronchial stump
we're now ready to close the chest since
we've done a pneumonectomy we do not
drain the chest but we put a tube in
anteriorly until the chest has been
closed now the reason for this is that
with the patient in the right lateral
decubitus the mediastinum gravitates
toward the right side and if this were
allowed to continue
there would be accumulation of air in
the left hemothorax
the dressing is applied the patient is
then placed back in the supine position
the anesthetist is then asked to inflate
the opposite lung which brings the
mediastinum back to the midline and then
this tube which we put in temporarily is
removed
this brings the mediastinum back in the
position that it should be
and the chest is now sealed
we want the cavity to fill up with
serous fluid fibrin will become
deposited and then ultimately there will
be organization of this area of course
if this were a lobectomy we would use
tubes to evacuate the cavity now here's
the lung you can see it's a large tumor
i'm cutting through the
the attachment of the pleura
and
we're coming down to the mass
and now we can see why this tumor
increased in size on our right is a one
can see the neoplasm on the left is a
hematoma and this increase in size that
was noticed within a relatively short
period of time is due to the hemorrhage
within the neoplasm
it'd be impossible for our tumor to grow
that fast
i'd like to again emphasize that the
results from the treatment of carcinoma
of the lung are not good so i said only
six percent of them are alive and well
at ten to five years it is before this
reason that it behooves all of us
to use the one weapon we have namely the
prevention of cancer of the lung which
is preventable almost entirely by
absence of smoking because as i
mentioned before with exception of
adenocarcinoma
they the all cancers of the lung are due
to cigarette smoking
so
you